hey guys it is top five time which means
I've got the five biggest stories of the
week all ready to go for you so let's
crack into it first up says creator and
controversial games personality Phil
fish is selling the rights to his
company and thurs after being harassed
online said harassment included hackers
obtaining his personal information
including his social security info
passwords and companies paypal account
and subsequently posting that
information online the attack was
seemingly a response to the support
filled fish express to fellow indie
developers zoe quinn who has been caught
up in her own batch of controversy that
the internet has decided it should weigh
in on over the last two weeks fish
tweeted about his decision to sell his
company and I please say no reasonable
offer will be turned down I am done I
want out
continuing on with the theme of things
on the internet that suck feminist
frequency crater Anita sarkeesian was
victim to abuse and death threats this
week writing on Twitter Sarkisian said
some very scary threats have just been
made against me and my family contacting
authorities now crater buffy the vampire
slayer' and my personal hero joss whedon
spoke out in support of psyche Xion
encouraging his followers to watch her
tropes vs. women in video game series
which takes a look at gender inequality
in gaming now it doesn't matter to me or
anybody else whose side you're on and
you're entitled to your own personal
opinions but there is never an excuse
for harassment or stress alrighty let's
get back to the news Sony are super keen
for VR probably because they have a huge
personal investment in it given project
Morpheus but nonetheless they're calling
it a game changer PlayStation worldwide
studios president Shuhei Yoshida has
said we have something here that we've
never experienced before working on game
development we always try to create a
new kind of experience and having VR
technology is almost unfair accessible
game development tools like unity are
keeping the prototype ideas flowing and
phony have said they're going all-in
with the technology the hack is really
were hacking this week and one of the
big ones they brought down what's the
PlayStation Network other major networks
including blizzards battlenet League of
Legends and path of Exile will also
brought down by denial of service DDoS
attacks a group on Twitter fessed up to
being the asshats causing the rest of us
a minor inconvenience although it's hard
to say exactly why these groups were
targeted
and finally dragon age inquisition with
announced to be including multiplayer
for the first time ever in the series
the RPG will have a full player
cooperative mode independent of the
single game players will be offered up a
variety of heroes from different classes
to choose from they can then explore
randomized environments contained within
3 multiplayer campaign gold gathered
here can later be spent on treasure
chests where players can pick up all
kinds of new loot equipment and what
have you the mode is set to get heaps of
deal see but Bioware have promised that
all of it will be free ask your question
of the day let me know whether or not
you're excited for the multiplayer mode
in dragon age inquisition that is it for
me this week stay lovely and be sure to
have yourself a wonderful weekend I will
see you soon